la source 1
c'est gilles verdez
qui était par hasard dans un couloir
par hasard derrière la porte
guillaume et mathieu ne se sont pas
adressé la parole les quinze premiers
jours de la saison
car mathieu est extrêmement vexés que
guillaume epu s'associent sur une boîte
puisque je rappelle ici par
donc les mettre tous ses oeufs dans le
jacuzzi avec cyril en qualité de co
producteur et pas lui alors je veux dire
une fois de plus ça prouve que gilles
verdez est un grand journaliste est
vraiment à grand avec un grand g c'est
vrai car je crois que le premier jour où
je suis arrivé on a déjeuné ensemble
c'est vrai ou pas vrai mais je voulais
pas me parler quand même
manger en tout cas oui parce que je
voulais pas me parler et on ira déjeuner
oui ça veut rien dire moi je vais te
révéler une chose c'est que cyril au
départ ils voulaient s'associer avec toi
et au moment de t'appeler
malheureusement il est tombé sur un ton
docte
ensuite voudrais pas remuer le couteau
dans la plaie mais tu sais un jour tu te
faire du shopping avec cyril oui il
n'est jamais venu ouais bah ce moment là
il était avec moi à l'univers de cadeaux
ouais
de cadeaux et de bijoux
tu as cette émission
qui couche avec qui
joker s'il vous plaît là on n'est pas là
pour ça merci voilà mais on viendrait
jade révélé qu isabelle était enceinte
s'il vous plaît pas non plus tout
révéler ouais cyril si vous devez
choisir entre les deux parce que c'est
vrai que les deux essais de gratter un
peu comme votre amitié de vous c'est
vraiment la bataille entre les deux
alors si mon amitié sincère lui c'est
parce que tu as les boîtes de prod voilà
le jour où tu devrais te lâchera le
ferry dans l'escalier moi du tout hein
c'est pas bien quand on écrit un livre
dont je ne joue pas au cas où il tombe
comme une association et parce que
j'attends tout et précédemment de
boisement et amener quelque chose
alors qu'est ce qui se passe et vous
donner les vraies raisons mathieu à ce
que valérie parle d'amitié et là on
rigole moi c'est du business donc c'est
vrai que cyril à un moment c'est didier
guillaume ou mathieu il a réfléchi il a
étudié les deux sociétés voulait le
verdict voilà pourquoi il vous a pas
pris manque de projets créatifs de votre
société
manque de perspectives à court moyen et
long terme et aux jantes et financière
peut convaincre rigueur fiabilité
moyenne j'ai la conclusion du rapport
votre société c'est du vent et le vent
ça vaut zéro
bravo gilles verdez je pense qu'on a
tout dit c'est dingue club êtes toujours
un pour remonter
[Rires]